Does micromanaging ever work?
Well,
yes.
And and more importantly,
does it work?
Yes.
Sometimes it works and more importantly,
sometimes you have to micro manage.
Um,
so you get somebody that isn't good at their job,
doesn't do a good job,
doesn't show up,
doesn't run things right.
Of course,
you know how you fix them.
You got to get into micromanage.
Well first of all,
you can't do mission failure.
So you've got to get it in their micromanage.
Once you're done micromanaging or,
or once you've got them up to speed,
then you can stop micromanaging.
This is,
this is totally good to go.
And even if you asked life or you know,
the other platoon commanders that worked for me or assist in between commanders
at work for me,
if when we say,
when they got to know me,
when they met me,
I was micromanaged master cause I'm in their grill.
Hey this,
you've got to do this.
No,
come over here a little bit.
No and wouldn't give me any slack.
But then as soon as I see that they get it,
of course,
then it's like,
okay,
you got this,
and I'm going to,
I'm going to macro manage and barely manage and let them run with it.
And so that's,
that's absolutely micromanagement is sometimes it's a necessity.
And by the weight,
if you're getting micromanaged,
that's a little bit of a red flag.
Sure.
You might have somebody that's a control freak that is a compulsive
micromanager,
and that sucks.
But you also might have somebody that doesn't trust you yet.
And so how do you build up their trust?
Is it by hiding from them?
No,
it's by being open and being like,
hey boss,
here's what I'm going to do.
You actually send them more information than they could even want.
You show them how responsible you are.
You show them what a handle you have on the situation,
and that's how you can help overcome the micromanager.
But if someone's not doing what they're supposed to do,
or they're failing,
or they're,
they're letting you down,
then yeah,
you gotta get in their grill and micromanage them.
The other time that I sort of said this is when you're mentoring someone,
that can also be viewed as micromanagement because now I'm sitting side by side
on my breathing down your neck a little bit.
And that might be viewed as micromanagement.
But again,
sometimes it's necessary.
If you don't know the ropes yet,
I got to show you the ropes.
That means I got to sit by you and make sure you know what I'm teaching.
So if you're teaching somebody something in a work environment that can also be
viewed as micromanagement,
it actually is because you're saying,
hey,
put this over here,
put that over here,
wait back off,
let me do this.
No,
no,
you don't know how to do it.
So I've got to show you how to do.
I'm teaching you how to do it.
So there's that and,
and then that's teaching and then sometimes you got to show people how to do it.
And I told that long story in here one time where I just said,
hey,
you sit and watch how I'm going to run this squad.
And I ran the squad and got fired up and told people where to go and moved down
the line and the platoon commander looked at me and said,
okay,
I can do that.
And as soon as you saw at one time,
he got it.
So that's sometimes micromanagement is okay.
The thing is you don't want to get stuck in the Rut of micromanagement.
So if I mentor you,
if I teach you,
if I instruct you,
if I show you the way doesn't mean stay there and keep micromanaging cause
you're not doing your job.
You shouldn't have the or the capacity to micromanagement to micromanage
everybody that works for you.
If you have that ability,
you're not doing your job,
you're not looking up the chain of command,
you're not looking out your troopers,
your subordinate leadership should be stepping up and leading and you should
expect that of them.
And if you have to micro management,
it should be a chore that you don't like doing.
And when you get in there and you micromanage for a certain amount of time,
then you say,
okay,
you got this.
You know,
um,
I'm stepping back.
And then you've got to step back because no one likes to be micromanaged.
So once you get people up to speed,
step back,
let them run.
Let your leaders lead.
Yeah.
Sometimes people who who like to micromanage or they feel compelled to,
they can fall in that trap where where it,
let's say they do need to micromanage and they'll get that pay off of,
Oh yeah,
I see this guy kind of getting it,
but instead of understanding the full scope of things where,
oh,
he's getting it now,
I need to,
I don't need to manage as much.
They'll be like,
they'll still start chasing that payoff of them getting it with their little
micromanagement,
you know?
So they'll like constantly need that.
Pay Off.
Some people.
Now that you mentioned,
some people micromanage because their ego,
they want to,
they want to exercise,
they want to do two things,
exercise their power over the person or,
or show off their knowledge to the person.
Yeah.
So those two are just such a pain and they're such a pain.
But you know what?
What do you do?
Okay,
cool.
I'm going to work harder.
I'm going to be ahead of you.
I'm going to get better at this and we're going to move on.
Yeah.
The showing off knowledge thing that,
that,
that it's in a micromanagement situation it seems like,
okay,
that's obviously you shouldn't do that and you could probably see it from a mile
away,
but,
but just in everyday life probably that's a compelling thing to want to show
people.
You ever,
you ever hear someone telling you something that you already know and you just
want to tell them?
Probably.
I already know.
I know,
I know.
You know,
like you don't have to explain it to me when really when you really kind of
search your own feelings,
it's not that they're wasting your time,
it's kind of that you just want to let them know that I have that knowledge,
worry about,
you know what I mean?
I see that all the time.
I feel that all the time.
Just got to like find your talk or any barrier.
But I think that's,
that's a real compelling,
like one desire,
you know,
to,
to show,
hey,
I already know that.
Or look how much I know,
you know.
Yet people definitely like that.
It's,
it makes them feel good and look at what I know,
you know.